salut les terriens salut les terriens ce
soir on perd nous accueillons jean
pierre pernaut
[Musique]
jean pierre pernaut bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes ici ce soir pour
répondre à la question qui m'obsède est
ce que vous auriez un bon fabricant de
sabots en bois oui on en a plein ça
reviens moi parce que j'ai cassé les
miens je sais moi mais non on sait pas
quoi faire bien plus l'émission
s'appelle salut les terriens et le
groupe également de pompiers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
jean pierre pernaut re bonsoir vous
occuper le fauteuil du jt de 13h de tf1
depuis le 22 février 1988 ça vous épate
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
24 ans et trois mois et voilà alors tous
les jours un téléspectateur sur deux
soit 7 millions de français vous regarde
et nous aussi on vous regarde
bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est
absolument superbe une fête superbe
superbe image et ses superbes aussi les
endroits superbes des villages superbe
superbe endroit aussi je lis coccinelle
ces jolies plantes et ses fleurs de
jolies fleurs d'une autre très jolie
fait de jolis bateaux une jolie
promenade ou formidable opération qu une
formidable performance sur formidable
toujours aussi magique je voulais ville
une très belle région encore une belle
région et des villages charmants autres
belles images belles histoires en tout
cas des images magnifiques ses paysages
magnifiques un endroit merveilleux un
endroit merveilleux je vous l'avais de
saboter des régions s'en lasse pas c'est
phénoménal
sur internet
ces prêts seront jamais vu ça des petits
montages de ce type c'est vrai que c'est
bien fait c'est plein d'humour et c'est
sympa alors jean-pierre pour préparer
cette émission j'ai regardé votre
journal toute la semaine et j'ai eu
envie de voter pompidou c'est normal ça
n'ont toujours pas de prompteur n'ont
jamais réussi à en dénicher en bois dans
le lycée
ça vous manque pas le compteur
j'en veux pas je jamais moi j'aime
beaucoup improvisé j'aime bien voilà
j'ai des notes et puis je je je vis
j'essaie de vivre le journal et
l'actualité alors dites moi jean-pierre
depuis 24 ans que vous nous parler des
derniers souffleur de verre de la vallée
de girou l'est vous êtes obsédé par ça
devrait pas être mort n'a plus le temps
non il ya quelques années il ya vingt
ans et je peux le dire on parlait de ces
métiers là comme des métiers en voie de
disparition alors que les japonais
parler de leurs trésors vivants quand
ils ont les artisans de ce type et
aujourd'hui ça revient à la mode il ya
plein de jeunes qui vont vers ces
métiers voilà céramiste et autres on
essaie de les mettre en valeur alors
votre trésor n'est pas seulement le plus
regardé de france et d'europe c'est
aussi le plus critique est en libération
se moque en disant ce jt en sabots
crottés révérend les belles régions les
mettez oublié et la mouse ardéchoise
cuisiné par grand maman c'est pas pour
rien cette preuve la première
destination touristique mais on a des
richesses et j'essaie de les montrer
dans la partie de magazine du journal
après l'actualité qui est bien différent
mais en fait vous faites le jt pour les
touristes japonais et c'est ça il ya
beaucoup de gens qui nous regardent sur
internet ailleurs au canada au japon et
d'expatriés qui aime bien se retrouver
dans le journal même bruce toussaint le
doubs bruce tout ça que j'adore ac est
vraiment un mec cool mais même lui il
dit que pernod soit droite conservateur
et réac ça ne me pose pas de problème le
souci c'est qu'il expose ses opinions
dans le journal télévisé alors les
propos de tout ça on était des formats
écrit il n'a jamais dit ça alors l'image
du père notre droite est ce qu'il ya un
rapport entre la droite et les régions
oui je ne sais pas ce qu'il y avait un
terroir quand même le côté as tu revois
la terre elle ne ment pas parce que
votre émission s'appelle salut les
terriens qui élèvent droite non bon ben
alors
les martiens
j'essaie de faire mon métier je crois
que si on avait un journal orienter un
journal c'est le journal on raconte la
vie des gens telle qu'elle est avec les
préoccupations les difficultés les
crises les le chômage le pouvoir d'achat
on en parle bien plus que dans d'autres
éditions plus institutionnel dans
d'autres chaînes doivent être très très
combatif et heureusement michel
houellebecq vous a rendu un hommage
incroyable dans la carte et le
territoire
il vous a donné l'absolution en quelque
sorte il dit le trait de génie de pernod
a été de comprendre qu'après les années
fric et frime le public avait soif
d'écologie d'authenticité de vraies
valeurs ils parlent de vous en dix ans
une personnalité visionnaire je n'ai pas
rencontré depuis me fait rire est fier
de ça marie et il ajoute pernaut partant
de l'actualité immédiate rapide violence
insensée et accomplissant chaque jour
cette tâche messianique messi avec
venessia nick consistant à guider le
téléspectateur terrorisé et stressé vers
les régions idylliques d'une campagne
préservée est ce que vous aviez imaginé
un jour vous seriez célébré par le plus
grand écrivain france jamet et toi les
critiques dont vous parlez depuis le
début de l'émission n'ont pas d'accord
mais toutes ces critiques que m'avait
énormément avant houellebecq y en a
beaucoup moins depuis woods ex mandat va
là alors jean-pierre vous avez écrit
avec votre femme nathalie marquay
pernaut et jean-claude y sert une pièce
de théâtre intitulée sillage à matignon
qui se joue du mercredi au samedi à 19
heures au théâtre du gymnase le pitch
c'était un homme politique appelée à
être premier ministre qui se fait filmé
à son insu lors d'une soirée déguisée
avec des copains la vidéo va faire le
tour du net et détruire sa carrière et
son comble c'est ça c'est internet
aujourd'hui qui a modifié la donne
aujourd'hui une phrase une image volée
sortie de son contexte par sur un site
on sait pas en quel est le sérieux de ce
site ça passe d'un site à l'autre ça ça
fait un buzz comme on dit et puis c'est
inarrêtable autrefois les corbeaux de
village avait un rayon de nuisance
limitant à leur village aujourd'hui bel
corvo de village son rayon de nuisance
il est mondial sur le net talence bien
la pièce ça marche bien c'est comme ça
qu'on l'a prolongé au théâtre de noël et
le public rit et c'est l'essentiel et
les cadettes d'une première pour moi de
voir texte on a écrit avec nathalie et
jean claude sur scène c'est c'est
jouissif c'est formidable d'entendre le
public rire et de voir les comédiens
s'accaparer un texte alors c'est un
petit peu autobiographique parce qu'en
2005 lorsque nathalie a participé à
l'émission de tf1 la ferme célébrités on
lui avait prêté une liaison avec un
autre candidat ouais ça a fait les choux
gras de la presse people étaient pas
internet à l'époque c'était la presse à
ce qu'en dit à scandale bon ben c'est
tout c'est on a fait des procès contre
les les gens qui ont écrit des conneries
et puis on a gagné ses procès et puis
voilà c'est tout elle a gagné 337 milles
euros mais dont une partie a été une
grande partie a été déduite des frais
d'avocats a été remise à son association
qui s'appelle petit toit mais c'est la
nation qui est de beaucoup la recherche
contre le cancer et nathalie ayant elle
même était malade mais au moins cela
aura servi à sa mère si voici alors
alors vous dites effectivement en
épousant une miss france j'ai commencé à
intéresser les paparazzi et les vendeurs
de papier oui c'est normal c'est
tranquille avant avant j'étais 38 non ma
campagne j'ai les jardinets nom puis
après le fait le succès du journal bon
mais c'est tout on a une personnalité au
douar 1 on doit vivre avec ça on va
essayer de s'exposer un minimum
parfois on met le doigt dans la
confiture maintenant est une séance
photo et puis après on a d'autres et
puis après on arrête ouais bon là on ne
veut on arrêtait tout ça quand on sort
avec une miss france et ce canal on n'a
pas envie de tenter sa chance avec une
miss univers mais j'en suis pas loin
puisque nathalie était 6e dauphine de
miss monde en 1981 après quoi
en tous les cas c'est comme une belle
réussite pour le fils de la pharmacienne
de t-mobile et quand même non oui mais
j'étais j'ai vu mon père était
industrielle dans la région de l'outil
ma mère était pharmacien dans un petit
village et puis j'imagine pas une seule
seconde travaille un jour à la télé ni
même dans la presse et puis ça m'est
venu vers 14-15 ans d'avoir envie des
durées de raconter ce qui se passait
dans mon village et puis ailleurs et
puis après il ya une image qui vous
résume assez bien d'ailleurs à l'époque
dequevauviller c'est le camp des alliers
chercher le lait dans un pot en état il
souhaite une musique et ils vont je suis
quand même mais ya quelques années et à
l'époque je me souviens quand j'étais
petit et des gens qui venaient à la
pharmacie de ma mère en voiture à cheval
et c'est vrai que je faisais à côté
d'une ferme et j'avais de toi dans ton
chercher le lait et vos premiers ébats
amoureux c'est dans la paille mais
comment vous savez je n'avais jamais dit
à personne voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nathalie en fait nous y aller draguer à
miss france je vais pas draguer on s'est
retrouvés côte à côte et il embarque oms
il ya eu 1 c'est madame de fontenay qui
avait organisé le truc où elle avait mis
nathalie à côté de vous et il ya une
fille qui s'était assise à la place de
nathalie était chez nous quant à terry
est arrivé à l'as wihr est la fille pour
vous soyez à côté c'est madame de
fontenay qui a tout fait en fait non où
nolan à la pâte ou fait m'avait dit tu
vous serez à côté de mon rayon de soleil
nathalie marquay miss france 87 aidera
les génial et je vois arriver une nana
très moche et je me dis qu'est ce que
c'est que cette histoire mais le
font-elles si mauvais goût et puis au
bout de quelques minutes et une autre
fille qui est arrivé nathalie et voilà
et la voilà là ça a été tout de suite
quoi la fir et la brousse et puis voilà
en plus c'est vrai et alors tout de
suite sincérité s'énoncer donateurs sa
galère a raconté puis j'ai découvert
voilà c'est cette jeune femme que je
connaissais pas qui
et puis qui très vite me raconter c'est
sa vie son cancer sont rasées après je
parler librement du cancer avec
quelqu'un et puis quand je vois la pêche
qu'elle a aujourd'hui mais font parler
du cancer il faut dire aux gens qui ont
le cancer de se bagarrer ouais
et alors
deux jours plus tard voulu envoyer un
bouquet de roses blanches avions eu son
adresse comment penser à tout
j'avais pas sur la vraie gérer son
téléphone l'un avait quand même
griffonné le soir de l'interaction et
puis j'ai demandé aux fleuristes de lui
trouver ceux de savoir où elle était
couchée et après vous avez conclu assez
vite on a composé
un an après il ya un enfant qui naissait
un tout récent et moreno voit on a eu
nos deux enfants assez rapide et la
grosse houle a pu enlever
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux